la grabación.
Vamos a ver.
y comparto pantalla
pantalla
un segundillo
segundo.
Vale, ayer estuvimos viendo,
bueno, empezamos a ver el tema de las
topologías de de redes a nivel a nivel
físico,
¿vale? Empezamos por las de por las de
punto a punto.
A ver qué estamos por aquí.
Topologías de red. tenemos en primer
término una clasificación entre físicas
y las lógicas,
¿vale? Y luego
dentro de la de
nivel físico tenemos
pues nada, punto a punto. Eh, ¿alguien
sabría decirme que ayer sí que lo lancé
cómo conectar un par de juegos, un par
de ordenadores, dos ordenadores con
Windows 11, por ejemplo, o con Windows
10 con mediante un cable RJ? Sí, esa
sería la conexión, pero el cable tendría
que ser de alguna manera especial o
lo sabéis. Eso nos serviría cualquier
cable normal. Vamos al chino y compramos
un cable R
cualquiera, nos serviría.
Vale, tendría que ser un cable cruzado.
Tendríamos que preparar o tener un cable
cruzado, ¿vale? Para poder hacer esta
conexión,
¿vale? Eso simplemente un inciso, ¿vale?
En en lo de la
topología de punto a punto, por ejemplo,
aquí nos pone el ejemplo de de de
telefonía, ¿vale?
Sí que estaba por aquí. A ver, en todas
este tipo no tiene ningún tipo de
estructura, por lo menos su estructura
como tal es muy básica. No es más que
llevar un cable en don en donde en un
extremo tiene un dispositivo conectado y
en el otro extremo tiene otro, por
ejemplo, con como la telefonía
convencional, ¿vale? Se refiere a
telefonía fija,
sería eso, ¿no? Telefonía convencional,
no. No sé a qué se refiere el ejemplo.
Podríamos conectar un teléfono, por
ejemplo, los datos de un teléfono los
podemos conectar con un ordenador
mediante el puerto USB.
Pero bueno, dentro del entorno de redes
y de transmitir información a través de
de protocolos y de y de
estandarizaciones, pues el tema de de
llevarlo de de conectar a través del de
la tarjeta de red dos ordenadores, lo
haríamos así, o sea, una conexión
sencilla. Quiero pasar los datos que
tengo en D, por ejemplo, los quiero
pasar todos a al otro ordenador y no
tengo wifi y no o no quiero poner wifi o
yo que sé, ¿vale? Cualquier cualquier
circunstancia, ¿vale? Pues con esto
puedes, pero necesitarías un cable
cruzado para poder conectarnos.
Ya ya llegaremos a eso que está está un
poquito así más para adelante, ¿vale? un
bus lineal en una red. A ver, aquí en la
imagen esta, esto sería en bus, o sea,
sería una una un cable y de él saldrían
ramificaciones, ¿vale? Eh,
cada se conecta un cable central, a este
se le conoce como bus. Toda la
transmisión de datos entre nodos
ocurre mediante este canal de
comunicación y es recibida con todos los
nodos simultáneamente. La topología de
red en bus, evidentemente, no es la
ideal para sostener en conexión a muchos
dispositivos
de una manera eficiente, ya que todos
estarían empleando un mismo canal de
transmisión. Esto podremos verlo.
Vamos a ir haciendo ejemplos con es que
nos va a quedar más claro a todos
utilizando el paquet traer
lo que pasa que está a nivel muy
pequeño.
Adelante.
Es tuyo.
No,
no es tuyo. Estaba donde yo estaba
sentado. Vale,
vale.
Ahíado.
Sí, se lo han dejado en mi clase. Se
es una tablet, ¿no?
Con el portátil ya.
Ha sido con el portátil, ¿no? Claro. O
sea, te has sido solo con el portátil,
¿no?
Vale, voy a hacer las letras un poco más
grandes.
Se puede cambiar eso.
Sí, sí, sí. está en opciones,
preferencias
y en las fuentes, pues nada, así un poco
más grandes que se deja uno la vista
aquí.
Me gustaría hacer los iconos más
grandes, pero eso no lo he encontrado
ya.
No.
Ah, no la tengo al
eh
que tengo la fuente
supongo.
Sí. Entonces lo que hace es el tamaño de
la fuente hace un poco más grande, pero
tampoco
tampoco es mucho, ¿eh?
Vale, la fuente esa sí que lo ha
cambiado.
Eso sí que lo ha cambiado. Sí,
eso nos lo cargamos
y eso también. Vale. Bueno,
ahora crearemos ejemplos.
Vale, estábamos en bus con la del bus.
Vale,
no es la ideal para sostener en conexión
a muchos dispositivos de una manera
eficiente. O sea, lo que se busca
también cuando diseñamos una red es
darle un poquito de eficiencia.
decir que aquello no sea un cuello de
botella que digamos, madre mía, esto no
va ni ca al aire.
Este tipo de redes se ven en empresas
pequeñas y en el uso doméstico.
Vale.
Vale. Red en estrella, la topología en
estrella.
Redu, a ver.
Vale, aquí lo veis también
sería un dispositivo central
del que, a ver, del el que el que está
conectado a a una serie de nodos,
¿vale?, a su alrededor.
Reduce la topología estrella, reduce
reduce la posibilidad de fallo de red
conectando todos los nodos a un nodo
central. Cuando se aplica una red basada
en la topología estrella, este
concentrado central
reenvía todas las transmisiones
recibidas de cualquier nodo periférico a
todos los nodos periféricos de la red,
algunas veces incluso al nodo que lo
envió.
Todos los nodos periféricos se pueden
comunicar con las demás con los demás
transmitiendo o recibiendo del nodo
central solamente un fallo en la línea
de conexión de cualquier nodo con el
nodo central provocaría el aislamiento
de ese nodo respecto a los demás.
el chat que lo tenía cerrado.
Vale.
Eh,
pero el resto de sistemas, o sea, un
fallo en la línea de conexión de
cualquier nodo, o sea, imaginar que
falla aquí, ¿vale? ¿Qué se qué pasaría?
pues que el resto seguiría funcionando,
¿vale? Imaginad que este este de esto
falla, ¿no? Vale, aquí falla, pues el
resto seguiría funcionando, ¿vale?
El tipo de concentrador UP que se
utiliza en esta topología, aunque no es
muy soleto, se suele usar comúnmente Se
suele usar comúnmente un switch. O sea,
¿sabéis la diferencia entre W y switch?
¿Qué ha pasado?
[Música]
Está jorobada. Ponte otra.
Vamos aar por aquí que no
la usa
[Música]
Intento a ver si la voy a meter un poco,
pero vamos, no sé.
Ya te digo, es que esa la usa
precisamente todo el mundo.
Vale, os decíais si sabéis la diferencia
entre entre un un U y un switch. Un
Ahora lo veremos
con ejemplo también.
La diferencia principal radica entre en
que el U eh envía a todos los a todos
los host que están conectados a él y el
switch lo dirige inteligentemente hacia
hacia el lugar que que va dirigido.
Ahora lo veremos con el packet 13.
La desventaja radica en la carga que
recae sobre el nuevo central. La
cantidad de tráfico que deberá soportar
es grande y aumentará conforme vayamos
agregando más nodos periféricos,
¿vale? Lo que la hace poco recomendable
para redes de gran tamaño. La verdad es
que que sí que puede ser un poco
farragcoso
cuando cuando aquello adquiere
dimensiones, ¿vale? Reden en árbol o
jerárquica,
que sería esto,
esta de aquí, ¿vale?
una una topología en árbol. Esto sonará,
¿no?, del año pasado.
Sí.
Una topología en árbol, también conocida
como topología jerárquica, puede ser
vista como una colección de redes en
estrella ordenadas en una jerarquía.
Este árbol tiene nodos
periféricos individuales que requieren
transmitir a y recibir de otro nodo
solamente y no necesitan actuar como
repetidores o regeneradores. Al
contrario que en las redes de estrella
la función del nodo central se puede
distribuir.
Los nodos individuales pueden quedar
aislados de la red por un fallo puntual
en la ruta de conexión del nodo.
Para aliviar la cantidad de tráfico que
se necesita para retransmitir en su
totalidad a todos los nodos, se
desarrollaronos centrales más avanzados
que permiten mantener un listado de las
identidades de los diferentes sistemas
conectados a la red. Estos switch de red
aprenderían cómo es la estructura de la
red transmitiendo paquetes de datos a
todos los nodos y luego observando de
dónde vienen los paquetes también
utilizado como un como un enchufe o
artefacto.
[Música]
Vale. Red en anillo o circular.
Una red en anillo conecta todos sus
equipos en torno a un anillo físico o
cada uno se conecta a su adyacente. Se
cae, si se cae un nodo o un cable, la
red sigue funcionando dependiendo de la
distribución. En caso de romperse el
anillo, la red caería.
Actualmente tampoco se usa.
Vale. Y redes malla.
Claro, esta es más cara de implementar.
Bueno, la topología mallas la que cada
nodo está conectado a todos los nodos.
De esta manera es posible llevar los
mensajes de un nodo a otro por distintos
caminos. Si la red de malla está
completamente conectada, no puede
existir absolutamente ninguna
interrupción. O sea, imaginad que este
de aquí falla,
pues los demás siguen recibiendo y tal.
O imaginad que esto falla, este cable
nos falla, ¿vale? Este sigue recibiendo.
Este sigue recibiendo y los demás
también, cosa que no pasaba aquí, por
ejemplo. Bueno, aquí sí que sería, pero
imaginad que a ver cómo me lo monto.
Bueno, que se queda aislado, ¿no? Yo que
sé. Pues ese dejaría de recibir
aquí imaginad un corte ahí.
Pues todo esto se queda fuera.
Claro. Imaginad un corte, espera.
Imaginar ahí un corte, ¿no? Todo esta
sección se queda fuera,
mientras que esta sí que seguiría.
Vale, si la red de malla está completa,
no puede existir absolutamente ninguna
interrupción en las comunicaciones. Esta
topología, a diferencia de otras, no
requiere de un nado central, con lo que
se reduce el riesgo de fallos y por ende
el mantenimiento periódico. Lo que pier
lo que lo que te cuesta más de de
implementar. Luego, por otro lado, pues
te te lo ahorras a la hora de de tener
un mantenimiento.
Las redes en malla pueden prescindir del
enrutamiento manual o apenas requerir
atención para el mantenimiento de este.
Vale. Familiares de protocolos.
A ver.
Vale, llegaremos al modelo. O sí,
a ver, es teoría, ¿vale? Que que sí que
hay que tenerla. Es, yo entiendo que la
clase es así un poco
peñazo. Vamos a ver la diferencia si
queréis, para hacerlo así un poquito más
o menos, entre switch y, ¿vale? Y vemos
ahí un ejemplo práctico y luego
continuamos por aquí.
Así no nos,
¿vale? Que luego sí que lo veremos,
¿vale? En dispositivos y tal.
Vale, pues estamos estamos por aquí.
Vale,
vale. Pues imaginemos que tenemos,
vamos a crear, por ejemplo, No,
pero
Switch
o mejor tenemos un No, espera, de aquí
que manía de pellarlo de ahí.
Bueno, lo cogemos de aquí switch lo
dejamos ahí.
Vale, vamos a un PC.
Le vamos a poner, le vamos a asignar.
la IP automática.
Vale,
vale.
Vale, hemos creado estos otros. Vamos.
Vale, ahora lo conectamos mediante,
bueno, lo hacemos de forma manual,
eh,
tal que así,
tal que así. A ver, si utilizamos el el
rayo este, eh, lo que nos lo hace es lo
cone lo conecta de forma automática
al puerto más que él considere más más
oportuno. Vale. Vale. Entonces,
vale, ya nos ha asignado una, no le
hemos puesto nada ni, o sea, dónde tiene
que
no le hemos asignado dirección IP ni
nada de eso, simplemente para que veáis
cómo funciona un un y cómo funciona un
switch,
que en principio podrían servir para lo
mismo,
¿vale? ¿Qué hace el U?
Le lanzamos un paquete desde aquí y
queremos que llegue hasta aquí,
¿vale? Y nos dice que ha sido correcto.
Vale, nos vamos a la simulación
y ahora veremos
lo que hace. nos envía el paquete
y nos lo envía las dos máquinas.
Imagin que tenemos 10 máquinas
conectadas. Nos lo hubiera enviado a las
10. No timiza realmente. Está
sobrecargando la red de de
tráfico. Vale,
el switch, sin embargo,
este nos lo cargamos.
Lo conectamos.
y esperamos que se active la red.
Una lo veremos aquí, ¿vale? Cuando
cuando este icono esté en verde es que
ya está que ya está conectado
completamente. Para los que no hayáis
usado
el el packet packet tracer.
A ver, espera
si nos venimos aquí.
O sea, podemos hacer un
IP config renew, ¿vale? Por ejemplo, si
queremos volver a a recibir una nueva
dirección IP, podemos hacerlo también de
esta manera. O sea, esto actúa. Espera,
se me colocado. Vale,
fijaos, está encendido el ordenador.
Vale, ¿cómo lo apagamos? Dándole al
botón. Pinchamos aquí y se apaga.
Y ya si ve ya como veis se ha
desconectado, ¿vale? O sea, es muy muy
interactivo, ¿vale? Aunque parece un
programa muy ladrillo,
pero realmente es que tiene tiene
opciones que dices, "Ostras, esto en
serio es así." O sea, tiene los routers,
por ejemplo, pues eh o sea, ¿cómo luego,
bueno, esto lo iremos viendo, ¿vale?
¿Cómo? ¿Cómo ponerle una tarjeta wifi a
un ordenador?
No te va a dejar ponerla así como así.
Tienes que que saber cómo.
Vale, entonces ahora le damos le lo
arrancamos, ¿vale? Y ya volvería a su
estado de arrancar a pedir, ¿vale?
Dámela porque le hemos dicho, asciéndame
una dirección IP de forma automática
mediante el protocolo de HCP.
A ver,
esto va esto
fica
esto. Vale, sería aquí.
haremos con
Estamos ahí. Vale,
vale. Nos nos está diciendo la dirección
IP que tiene
ese ordenador
o ese dispositivo.
Vale, es que quiero verlo desde aquí.
Vale, 169 254. Ahora veremos este tipo
de de direcciones IP así un poco
marcianas.
Eh, 169, 254, 118 57,
que coincide con esta, ¿vale? Que es la
misma. Vale, si le decimos, a ver si me
deja porque es que esto, a ver,
vale, llegamos hasta el final, ¿vale?
Eh, F3, no, aquí no me deja.
IP config.
Y aquí en teoría nos debería renovar, no
sé, no sé cómo funciona con el pack, no,
no me ha dejado. Eh,
igual es poniendo.
Bueno, pero para el caso, o sea, es que
no era el ejemplo que os quería poner.
Lo que queríamos ver era la diferencia
entre Google y switch.
No me deja. Vale, nada, no pasa nada.
No era esto lo que queríamos ver, así
que no pasa nada. Vale, vale, tenemos
este de aquí. Y ahora lo que vamos a ver
es cómo funciona
un switch.
A diferencia de cómo funciona,
le le mandamos un paquete desde este
desde este host hasta este otro,
¿vale? Y correctamente ha llegado. El
otro ha fallado porque no existe ya el
nos hemos cargado el H. Vale, entonces
tenemos aquí lo que pasa que igual se me
pone a
Bueno, vamos a ver. Vale, vemos que
llega llega hasta el switch y el switch
nos lo mandará únicamente al host. Vale,
esa es la diferencia. Imaginar esto
multiplicado por 10.
Pues es mogollón de tráfico que no tiene
sentido.
Vale, queda claro, ¿no?
Vale.
Sí,
vale.
Vamos
ahora al
a las familias de protocolos
y luego el y luego las
las capas del modelo que eso también
sonará, ¿no? El año del año pasado,
¿vale? Para que todas las redes que
hemos visto en la unidad tengan sentido,
es importante tener en cuenta los
protocolos.
¿Sabéis algún protocolo? ¿Sabéis decirme
alguno? Así sin más.
El
TCP, por ejemplo, sería también el de
DHCP.
Vale. Eh, vale. El estudio de las
tecnologías de redes se simplifica.
estructurando. Hola.
Hola. Hay alguien que no tiene portátil.
Sí.
¿Y no lo tienes?
En casa lo tengo.
Es que no tiene.
Para estudiar informática prácticamente
es infidera
porque yo ahora ya sé que tienes co.
Yo ahora tengo libre alguna aula, pero
cuando empiezo los cursos de labora ya
no las tendré. Yo hoy o mañana el
próximo día que vengáis os dejo el aula
dos.
Nos vamos al aula dos. Es que sabes lo
que pasa es que los ordenadores de aquí
no se puede cargar nada en ese
ordenador.
¿Me explico?
Sí.
Por eso normalmente tenéis portátiles
por máquinas virtuales y por cosas.
Claro,
yo hoy te puedo dejar un aula para la
semana que viene, pero no te puedes
grabar nada en el ordenador.
Vale,
vale.
Sí,
espera que quiero quiero hablar una
cosa.
Sí,
disculpa un momento.
Mi consejo es que en vez de móvil te
compro un ordenador del puesto.
supuestamente va a comprar este
más que nada porque haces cosas aquí, te
las llevas a casa, las trabajas en casa,
las traes aquí
y utilizar mis ordenadores pues es un
poco más complicado. Pasa
el tema de los
es un radio
estaba con Absolutamente
a si nos lo hace fácil.
Vale,
un segundo, muchachos enseguida.
Vale, perfecto.
Lo más importante es que tengas espacio.
Sí, sí,
ya porque la virtuales se ocupa más,
aunque tengo bastante espacio en plan de
de libros y menos
por
yo es que tengo uno, pero es
estuve viendo con no
[Música]
De hecho, el que te parecido est 600
que no me acordar
[Música]
este pier
y Quito est
si no no vas a usar ni para jugar ni
nada
de este vato, pero va cuando
tienen 7 años
con que tira a uno y me tiro.
[Música]
Está
mirado
como media hora y inicios
está vamos para notarlo.
Chicos, me vais a disculpar que vosotros
unos hermanos de Caesa que vienen desde
Caesa. Vosotros estáis en prestar en
segundo.
Yo no lo sé. Yo estoy en SMR1 semi en
semi
en semi
desde semipresencial.
Sí, pero yo lo aquí porque
sí, por eso tienes ordenadora y tú estás
en presencial en segundo, pero te ha
quedado esta asignatura y lo haces así.
Vale, pues de momento eso sí, tú teete
tu ordenador siempre la caras mejor.
Tú aquí puedes tú estás en el aula 11.
Estoy en la
en ese pues a ver si mañana os lo puedo
arreglar y en tu y en tu ordenador haces
las cosas porque es que claro, por la
mañana estáis dos de presencial y no
dejó que se haga nada.
Este fin de si
no pero no pasa nada vamos a ver por la
mañana nos ha presenciado que tenéis el
ordenador que vienen de distancia tienen
que venir con ordenador porque no les
dejo grabar nada en vuestros
ordenadores.
Tú como sí que tienes un ordenador aquí
porque vienes en el presencial, ¿vale?
Y ven este aconsejo se trabaja mucho
mejor así.
Vale,
sí, no me de manera es que cuando me
dicho si estos chicos vienen de
presencial, digo, entonces no pasa nada
su ordenador, yo no dejo que los de
distancia utilicen vuestros ordenadores
porque en otras ocasiones os han borrado
cosas que han pasado
vale pues nada
mañana os dejaré aula 11 libre vale
mañanao difícil
más duras me lo que hago
ser
Sí,
llevármelo por ahí también
si no no tengo otra cosa.
contin
Amen.
Yes.
Disculp.
Eh, ostras.
[Música]
Vale, ya está
Vale, vamos
con el tema de familias de de
protocolos.
Vale, para que todas las habíamos dicho
las bueno, pues protocolos como TCPIP,
eh DH DHP,
¿vale? Para que todas las redes que
hemos visto en la unidad tengan sentido,
es importante tener en cuenta los
protocolos.
El estudio de las tecnologías de redes
se simplifica estructurando las
distintas tecnologías involucradas en
las comunicaciones
en familias de protocolos de
comunicación en las que se definen
perfectamente las relaciones las
relaciones de unos con otros.
Un protocolo se define como el conjunto
de reglas perfectamente organizadas y
convenidas de mutuo acuerdo entre los
participantes en la comunicación.
La misión es regular la comunicación
dentro de estas,
¿vale? Conceptos dentro de los
protocolos.
Los protocolos están expuestos
públicamente como normativas o
recomendaciones. Los fabricantes que se
ajustan a estas normativas tienen la
seguridad de ser compatibles entre sí en
aspectos regulados por el protocolo.
¿Vale? El concepto de capa o nivel. Se
consiguen normalizar o estandarizar las
técnicas de comunicaciones favoreciendo
conectividad entre equipos de diversos
fabricantes.
Las capas están jerarquizadas, es decir,
cada capa se construye sobre su
predecesora. La misión de cada capa es
proveer servicios a las capas
superiores. Por ello, cada capa debe
ocuparse exclusivamente de su nivel
inferior.
La interfaz entre capas. Dos capas
consecutivas establecen relaciones de
comunicación.
Ahora veremos veremos ejemplos. Cada
capa negocia los servicios y se comunica
con las capas adyacentes. La
intercomunicación entre capas es la
interfaz o inter o interface de capa.
Interface de capa. Vale. Arquitectura de
una red.
La arquitectura de una red habréis oído,
¿no? Veces.
Sí.
La arquitectura de
Sí. Sí.
Es el conjunto organizado de capas y
protocolos que la red utiliza para
producir sus sus comunicaciones entre
nodos.
La organización de la red debe estar
clara para que los fabricantes de
software y hardware puedan diseñar sus
productos y sean compatibles con otros
que sigan la misma normativa
para que puedan ser interoperables. Se
dice que los equipos son interoperables
cuando siendo de distinta tecnología o
de diferentes fabricantes son
funcionalmente compatibles entre sí.
¿Vale? Sistemas abiertos.
El concepto sistema abierto fue
propuesto por la ISO como aquel sistema
compuesto por uno o más ordenadores, el
software, los periféricos, los procesos
físicos, los medios de transmisión de la
información, etcétera, que constituyen
un todo autónomo capaz de realizar un
tratamiento de la información.
¿Vale? Familias de protocolos usuales,
el modelo OSI, que no hemos llegado a él
todavía.
define un modelo que lo veremos ahora a
continuación define un modelo de
referencia para el estudio de las redes,
pero cada compañía diseña la red de
acuerdo con las tecnologías de las que
es propietaria.
La familia Network
eh ha sido el sistema operativo de red
más utilizado a nivel mundial gracias a
a su capacidad de crecimiento y la
optimización de los recursos. Netware
utiliza un protocolo propietario
desarrollado por Nobel denominado
IPXSPX.
Bueno, ha sobrevivido durante
aproximadamente unos 10 años, ya que
actualmente está en desuso desde que el
Boom de Internet hizo a TCPIP casi
universal.
Una de las diversas razones de su antes
de de interesaros por la por informática
y todo esto, ¿habéis oído algo de esto?
alguna sigla TCP igual sí que sonaba,
¿no?
Informática, ¿no?
Dime
antes de la informática o no.
Antes de antes no
vale. Pues es está así bastante
extendido, incluso trasciende pues eso,
el mundillo de de la informática, ¿vale?
ha sobrevivido durante aproximadamente
unos 15 años, ya que actualmente está en
desuso desde el mundo de internet que
hizo ATCPIP Casi Universal. Una de las
diversas razones de su de su uso es que
como los ordenadores y las redes
actuales pueden utilizar múltiples
protocolos de red, casi todos los sitios
con IPX usarán también TCPIP para
permitir la conectividad con internet.
y nos dice que a partir de la de la
versión 5 ya se ha reemplazado al IPX
por TCPIP, aunque sigue siendo posible
su uso.
Juegos de red antigua pone. No sé, no sé
qué juegos pueden utilizar esto. Vale,
familia Net BUI.
Bueno, eh esta familia es un protocolo
de nivel de red sin encaminamiento y
bastante sencillo utilizado como una de
las capas en las primeras redes de
micros. Vamos a ver las capas. Es que
estamos hablando de las capas y no y sin
saber de qué va. Vale, modelo de
referencia o luego si queréis
describimos así estas por encima,
¿vale? Modelo de referencia o sí. El
modelo OSI es el nombre del modelo de
referencia de una arquitectura de capas
para redes de ordenadores y sistemas
distribuidos propuesta por la ISO como
estándar de interconexión de sistemas
abiertos.
Osi es un modelo de referencia,
un punto de mira desde el que calibrar
cómo deben relacionarse unas redes con
otras.
El modelo propuesto por Osi estructura
los servicios
de red en siete capas o niveles.
La primera capa es la más cercana al
medio físico, la de transmisión,
mientras que la séptima capa es la más
cercana a las aplicaciones de usuario.
¿Os imagináis cómo cómo
Bueno, queda claro, no? en el en el
este, o sea, la primera capa sería a
nivel físico, estaríamos hablando de los
dispositivos y la y la la séptima
estaría más cercana, pues eso, al
software que estamos utilizando. Cada
nivel de capa maneja una unidad de datos
que coincide con la información que le
pasa la capa inmediatamente superior.
Veremos dibujos y cada nivel maneja una
unidad de datos que coincide con la
información que pasa de la capa o nivel
inmediatamente superior.
Los siete niveles de OSIS reciben los
siguientes nombres de mayor a menor.
físico, enlace, red, transporte, sesión,
presentación y aplicación.
¿Dónde estaría vuestro PC ahora mismo?
¿En qué capa?
En el PC.
¿Y dónde estaría el el
Adobe PDF? Este,
aplicación,
¿sí?
Y el wifi,
correcto.
En el nivel tres.
Vale,
vale,
vale. Los niveles orientados a la red,
los niveles inferiores
están más próximos a la red. De hecho,
la capa física se ocupa del hardware.
Por tanto, la capa física de enlace y de
red están orientadas a la red. El
lenguaje se maneja en esta subred.
Subconjunto de las tres capas
es más complicado de entender por el ser
humano. Por tanto, cuanto más próximo a
la capa de aplicación, más fácil será la
comunicación entre usuario y
dispositivo, es decir, orientados a la
aplicación. Vale, queda claro, ¿no?
O sea, es eh
tenemos una comunicación más cercana con
las placa, con las capas con las capas
cercanas a lo a a
o sea, no podemos comunicarnos con una
CPU, por ejemplo, ni con una tarjeta de
red así y pero sí que podemos
comunicarnos con el Word o con el AD PDF
o con el sistema operativo.
Vale, entre el emisor y el receptor se
establecen comunicaciones utilizando
protocolos determinados.
El mismo protocolo
debe estar presentado tanto en el emisor
como en el receptor. A continuación
describiremos brevemente las capas o
niveles que componen el modelo OSI.
[Música]
que un caramelo.
un caramelo que no
más si no se ofrecería M.
Vale,
vale. Y vamos a describir.
Entre el emisor y el receptor se
establecen comunicación
utilizando protocolos determinados. El
mismo protocolo debe estar representado
tanto el emisor como el receptor.
Eh, vamos a describir brevemente las
capas o niveles que componen el modelo
OSI.
La capa física o nivel uno, esta de
aquí. Luego tenía también por aquí. A
ver, eh,
bueno, da igual. Aquí queda habían
representado, o sea, es que no tiene más
era un dibujo más molón, pero pero
bueno.
V la ca la capa física nivel uno
se ocupa de definir las características
mecánicas eléctricas funcionales.
tengo garganta cascada, eh
eléctricas, funcionales y de
procedimiento para poder establecer y
liberar conexiones entre dos equipos. Se
ocupa de las transmisiones
de los bit expresados como señales
físicas,
¿vale? que
vale, ya hemos visto ejemplos antes,
¿no? De de la capa física,
¿vale? En la misión de la capa dos,
la capa de enlace
es establecer una línea de comunicación
libre de errores
que pueda ser utilizada por la capa
inmediatamente superior,
la capa de red, o sea, su capa
inmediatamente superior sería la capa de
red.
Bueno, por la descripción que hemos que
hemos ido viendo antes, ¿vale? Que van
inmediata inmediatamente con la capa
superior.
La capa de red, como el nivel anterior
opera con bits. La capa de enlace debe
fraccionar el mensaje en bloques o
tramas frames.
Serán enviados en secuencias por la
línea de transmisión a través de los
servicios de transmisión.
Este nivel
también se ocupa del tratamiento de los
errores que se producen. Esta capa se
divide en dos subniveles.
Subnivel de control de acceso al medio
MAC y control lógico de enlace, ¿vale?
Ll.
La capa de red.
Capa de red nivel 3
se ocupa del control de la subred.
Espera.
Hai
No tenemos que estar todo el rato yendo
hoy.
Vale,
seguir
que se despeje esto algún día. Vale.
La capa de red nivel 3 se ocupa del
control de la subred. La principal
función de este nivel es la de
encaminamiento, es decir, cómo elegir la
ruta más adecuada para que el bloque de
datos del nivel de red para que el
bloque de datos del del nivel de red,
¿vale? La capa transporte,
el nivel cuatro, es una capa de
transición entre los niveles orientados
a la red y los niveles orientados a las
aplicaciones.
La capa de transporte lleva a cabo las
comunicaciones entre ordenadores, es
decir, es el punto de donde emisor y
receptor cobran todo su sentido.
Un programa emisor puede conservar,
puede conversar con otro receptor.
En las capas inferiores esto no ocurre.
Las capas situadas por encima de este
nivel de abstracción del transporte
están orientadas a las aplicaciones y se
centran las funciones de aplicación. Por
ejemplo, la capa sesión del que sería el
nivel cinco.
Esta capa permite el diálogo entre
emisor y receptor estableciendo una
sesión. A través de esta se puede llevar
a cabo un transporte de datos ordinario.
En la capa de transporte, la capa de
sesión mejora el servicio de la capa de
transporte.
Vale, la capa de presentación nivel 6
sería esta de aquí. se ocupa de la
sintaxis y de la semántica de la
información que se pretende transmitir,
es decir, investiga en el contenido
informativo de los datos. Otra función
que cumple es la de comprimir los datos
para que las comunicaciones sean menos
costosas,
para cuando enviamos un paquete,
este generalmente va a comprimir, o sea,
no es no se envía así al tun, ¿vale?
La capa de aplicación si es la capa
superior de la jerarquía OSI. En esta
capa se definen los protocolos que
utilizarán las aplicaciones y procesos
de los usuarios.
Cuando ambos
procesos
cuando ambos cuando ambos, perdón,
cuando ambos procesos que deseen
comunicarse estén en el mismo ordenador,
utilizan las funciones del sistema
operativo para comunicarse.
Pero si estos dos procesos están en
diferentes ordenadores, se deben de
comunicar entre capas para producir la
conexión entre ellos. Se servirán de las
capas inferiores,
¿vale?
Y esto sería, ¿vale? Y aquí tenemos una
serie de de
ejemplos de capa. Esto, una cosa, eh,
los que venís de redes de segundo,
bueno, que estáis haciendo de nuevo
primero, vosotros estáis de alta en
tenéis
en el operativo
en TAME, en el en el Moodle.
Sí.
Y tenéis
Sí, sí, sí. Y y tenéis los apuntes estos
oí
de primero creo que no.
Claro. Y si tenéis tendréis otros
tendréis los que
Sí.
Los que tenga el profesor
tendrás que subir tú.
Voy a subir, voy a voy a crear un drive,
¿vale? Y de ahí vamos a todos y
vamos a a subir ejercicios y cosas
porque porque sí, porque creo que merece
la pena.
¿Vale? Entonces, en el momento que lo
cree os lo os lo digo, ¿vale? Y así ahí
tenéis todos los apuntes.
Mejor así,
¿vale? Tenemos ejemplos, ¿vale? En el
nivel siete, por ejemplo.
A ver, la cooperativa recoge los frutos
y negociar el precio. Bueno, sí, son son
sí un ejemplo de la cooperativa. Vamos
desde abajo hasta arriba
la carga al lugar de destino. El
transporte se le añada seguridad.
peso se reparte, ¿no? La cooperativa
recoge los frutos y negocia el precio de
venta con el mercado y decide en la
mercancía. Es que lo veo un poco,
Creo que que este ejemplo no me no me
acaba a mí de
No, ¿cómo lo veis vosotros?
Un poco raro.
Un poco raro, ¿verdad?
Esto lo veo así un poquillo raro,
hombre. Aquí quizá empaquetarse y
presentarse con cestas como Vale, este
sí que nos sirve. La seis sí que nos
serviría de ejemplo. Vale, en la siete
nos dice, "La cooperativa recoge los
frutos y negocia el precio de venta con
el mercado y decide enviar la
mercancía."
digamos, eh, vamos a ver, escribimos un
correo electrónico y decidimos enviarlo,
¿vale? ¿Qué hemos utilizado? La capa de
aplicación hemos utilizado, pues, no sé,
el Outlog o el Thunderbear o cualquier
gestor de correos,
incluso Gmail, ¿vale? Una vez recogidos,
los frutos deben empaquetarse y
presentarse con cestas con un peso
determinado para que ocupen un espacio
mínimo con el fin de facilitar el
transporte. Estas cajas, estas cajas van
precintadas. Esto es lo que hablábamos
aquello de
de que el de que la información se envía
en paquetes
comprimidos para que no te para que no
sean
para que no aquello no no se disparen,
¿vale? Para que no se
saturen las redes,
¿vale? El comprador y el vendedor se
ponen de acuerdo para hacer el envío en
ciertos días de la semana. Eso sería la
capa de sesión. Vale.
Vale. Sí, podría ser. Podíamos aplicarlo
en correo electrónico todo esto, eh,
pero pero bueno, así con
con este
con este ejemplo costumbrista de
No está mal. Vale, venga. La compañía de
transporte se compromete a entregar la
mercancia en el mercado en condiciones
óptimas.
Vale. Y aquí sí, exacto. Las
observaciones de este evento está en
contacto directo con los usuarios de la
comunicación. Vale. Sí.
Vale, se compromete a entregar la
mercancía al mercado. El nivel tres, la
compañía de transporte determina la
rutas posibles para efectuar el traslado
en la carga, así como la tecnología de
transporte más adecuada. Cada caja lleva
adherida una etiqueta que identifica la
caja al destino. Esto sería algo así
como el almacén de de yo que sé de
Amazon o algo así, ¿no? Que te que te
dirige los paquetes de o de AliExpress o
uno de estos.
Hombre, Alexpress no. Amazon sí que es
lo tiene más centralizado todo esto,
¿vale?
Al transporte. La capa dos en el enlace
al transporte se le añade seguridad. Si
tiene un exceso de peso, se reparten
varios contenedores más pequeños. Se
vuelve a precintar por seguridad si la
carga que llegan no es la prevista, se
declara inservible o se pide una nueva
carga.
¿Vale? y el transporte llevar la carga
al lugar de destino, que sería la capa
física del transporte, sería el camión,
el avión o lo que o lo que o el
repartidor de última milla. Vale,
vale, vale. Y ahora sí que podríamos ver
el tema. Ahora que sabéis lo que son las
capas,
nos vamos aquí que nos estn hablando de
capas.
No, un poquito más de lógica.
Vale, habíamos visto esta.
Estábamos con esta y vamos a a Sí, esta
la habíamos visto así por encima, ¿vale?
Net es un protocolo de nivel de red sin
encaminamiento, bastante sencillo,
utilizado como una de las capas en las
primeras redes de Microsoft, ¿vale?
Microsoft dispone de diversos sistemas
operativos para resolver las
comunicaciones en las redes de área
local. Todos ellos pensados para
convivir en una red utilizando el la el
protocolo que es un desarrollado por
IBM. Este protocolo a veces es
confundido con Net BIOS, pero Net BIOS
es sí es que del
porque no está saliendo fuera. No,
no,
no.
Lo que suena ser la
[Música]
que estaba llena de
estaba casi llena de de ayer.
Vale. Este protocolo a veces confundido
con Netbios, pero NetBOS es una idea de
cómo un grupo de servicios deben deben
ser dados a las aplicaciones,
¿vale? Debido a que no tiene
encaminamiento, solo puede usarse para
comunicar terminales en el mismo
segmento de red de red, pero puede
comunicar dos segmentos de red que estén
conectados mediante un puente de red.
Esto significa que solo es recomendable
para redes medianas o pequeñas. Para
poder usar este protocolo en redes más
grandes de forma óptima, debe ser
implementado sobre otros protocolos, IPX
o TCPIP. Y vamos a la familia de TCPIP.
La familia de protocolos de internet es
un conjunto de protocolos de red en los
que se basa internet,
¿vale? Y que permiten la transmisión de
datos entre computadoras.
En ocasiones se denomina conjunto de
protocolos TCPIP en referencia a los
protocolos más importantes que la
componen, que sería el protocolo de
control de transmisión y el protocolo de
internet,
¿vale? Sus siglas son TCP y B. Este,
¿vale?
Y luego ya lo que hemos estado viendo
las capas,
¿vale?
Vale, elementos de las redes. Esto es
menos chapa.
Vale, elementos de de la red. Con los
elementos de red terminamos de componer
el mapa de conocimientos necesarios para
entender el funcionamiento de una red.
En primer lugar, comentaremos la
importancia del cableado,
la conectorización y los espacios en los
que se localiza físicamente la red. El
elemento más específico de la red es el
cableado. Puede ser de cobre o de fibra
óptica. Pero no solo nos hemos de fijar
en los cables, sino también en los
conectores.
No todos los conectores pueden ser
terminadores de cualquier cable. Cada
tipo de cableado lleva su propio sistema
de conectorización. Vosotros el año
pasado climpasteis, eh, hicisteis
cables, ¿no? Hicisteis cables cruzados,
cables normales, de todo, ¿no?
Nosotros, hombre, pues podremos hacer
podemos hacer algo de eso en el aula,
en el aula de abajo. Pues claro, aunque
sea telepresencial, pues sí que podemos
quedar un día y dedicar la clase a
hacerla más práctica a los que podáis
venir.
Vale. Sí,
claro.
Vale. Eh, vale. Elemento, el elemento
más específico de la red es el cableado.
Bueno, esto ya ya lo ya lo hemos visto,
¿no? Todos los conectores. Eso estaba
ahí, ¿no?
Se oye ahí de vez en cuando,
¿vale? Pero no solo nos hemos de fijar
los cables, ¿vale? No todos los
conectores pueden ser terminadores de
cualquier cable. Cada tipo de cableado
lleva su propio sistema de
conectorización.
Los dispositivos específicos de red son
máquinas especializadas en alguna
función de red. ¿Vale?
Algunos de estos dispositivos trabajan
en alguno de los niveles de red, pero
otros absorben funciones de más de una
capa.
Anteriormente en el tema hemos visto
algunos conectores de red, ahora vamos a
citar otros también muy importante. Los
modems realizan conexiones remotas
mediante líneas telefónicas.
¿Alguien
ha visto los modens antiguos estos que
que se oían que empezaban pial?
Yo lo he vivido eh el tema de de esos
las velocidades de vértigo de internet
que ibas a lo mejor a 18k por segundo,
a 58
cas, tal.
Vale, concentradores y repetidores
regeneran la señal eléctrica en
distintos segmentos de red.
Commutadores, intercambios el tipo de
tramas de datos entre diferentes
segmentos de la red.
Encaminadores transportan paquetes entre
redes y pasadelas son los dispositivos
que operan los niveles más altos de OSI.
Otros dispositivos muy importantes en la
red son los nodos. Vale, que estábamos
hablando antes de nodos. Los nodos
pueden estar conectados a la red
mediante cable o de modo inalámbrico.
Cada nodo
requiere una interfaz de red o algún
dispositivo físico sobre el que pueda
interactuar el software de la red. Estas
tarjetas o dispositivos de red de poseer
la interfaz apropiada para la conexión
del cable o antena. O sea, por ejemplo,
una tarjeta de red Ethernet sería un
esto
lo que nos conectaría en a la a la red,
¿vale? Una tarjeta wifi.
Por último, todos los dispositivos
activos en la red tienen que ejecutar
operaciones informáticas, cumpliendo con
los protocolos de la red.
Para ello necesita un software, software
de red. En el nivel superior sean las
aplicaciones que proporcionan los
servicios avanzados de la red, es decir,
las aplicaciones que nos proporcionan
los sistemas operativos, correo
electrónico, mensajería electrónica,
software de comunicación, etcétera. Es
decir, los programas que maneja el
usuario, pero este software de red puede
ser muy variada.
En niveles inferiores se posicionan los
controladores
de las interfaces de conexión como
tarjetas de red o los models.
¿Vale? Y aquí hay una serie de enlaces.
Es que no quiero desde aquí ahora
cogerlo Bien.
Quiero ver también en la plataforma si
hay a ver si hay algún tipo de ejercicio
cerrado sobre esto o son preguntas tipo
test. Que la verdad
que las preguntas tipo
test es que se las pasas por la guía te
las hace y os quedáis igual.
que sí que acabéis rápido, pero no
aprendéis así. Entonces tampoco es
plano.
A ver, un segundo que entre que entre la
plataforma.
Vale, ya estaba.
Lo digo porque para la semana que viene
sí que estaría bien hacer algunos
ejercicios
y si acaso corregirlos. Vosotros como no
tenéis acceso a la al aquí a la
plataforma,
claro, si yo subo ejercicio
en la en la página del de la asignatura,
vosotros no lo veis.
Vale, es algo que que voy a hablar
mañana también
con dirección porque igual que os den
acceso, oye, en el en el este y así lo
tenemos todos. Es que creo que va a ser
lo mejor
independientemente de que luego al traí
subamos cosas y tal, ¿vale? Que luego ya
veremos cómo cómo hacemos las entregas
de ejercicio, si si las si se habilita
aquí algún espacio o las vamos subiendo
a drive. Eso ya, eso ya lo iremos
viendo. Vale.
Vale. Hablar con, a ver, hablar con
Salvador.
¿Estáis haciendo ya ejercicios? Por
ejemplo, de
os han mandado ya hoy el primer día.
[Música]
sois eh
tú eres, o sea, está Isaac,
está Alex,
Álvaro,
vale. Había uno de vosotros que además
tenía otra, no tenía que
había uno de vosotros que tenía
que tenía otro.
Sí, yo tenía sostenibilidad, pero he
hablado con el tutor y creo que al final
lo voy a hacer presencial. Estoy
esperando a que me lo confirmen.
¿Te la vas a hacer presencial? Perdona,
es que no no te oigo bien.
Eh, es que hoy como me han cambiado el
horario, pues puedo acceder la
presencial y he hablado con
eh mi tutor a ver si me la cambia y
estoy esperando a que me conteste. De
momento aún no sé nada. Vale, vale. No
lo digo por yo por hablarlo yo con
dirección y eso que te habiliten el
espacio de sostenibilidad también.
Sí, sí, tener lo tengo, pero como quiero
quiero ver si al final lo hago
presencial o online y estoy esperando
que me contesten a ver cómo lo hago.
Vale, pero dices que sí que que sí que
tienes acceso al espacio, ¿no? De la
plataforma de Tame.
Eh, sí, en Tam sí que tengo el apartado
de sostenerado. Sí que lo tengo.
Y de redes tienes, ¿no? Pero no con pero
no de esta clase, no. Tienes de
Exacto. Tengo redes, pero no tengo nada
en plan, no hay nada.
Vale, vale. No, claro, pues eso, eso sí.
Bueno, pues hay sostenibilidad. Lo vamos
a dejar en en standby, ¿vale? A ver cómo
cómo evoluciona. Y lo de redes sí que le
diré la dirección que os pongan
que os asen que os asen mi aula,
¿vale? Y ahí ya podremos
podréis ver, bueno, pues podremos subir
los ejercicios ahí directamente y así
los tenemos todos. Claro, es que creo
que creo que va a ser mejor.
Bueno, pues si os parece h lo la podemos
ir dejando que son 27
podemos ir dejando la clase. Y sí que me
gustaría preparar algún ejercicio aunque
sea de eso de de aunque sea a nivel de
terminología, ¿sabes? ¿Qué es esto? ¿Qué
es lo otro? Tal. Claro, tampoco hemos
tocado mucho.
Lo que sí que os voy a pedir a todos es
que os instaléis el packet TR, solo
tenerlo con con la fuente un poco grande
que se ve muy pequeño.
Vale, eso sí, para el próximo día. Así
que si lo podemos tener todo sería
genial.
Vale, pues eso sería. todo hoy.
Vale, perfecto. Hasta luego.
Venga, hasta luego.
[Música]
Álvaro. Eso.